let's talk about devs devs you you play
this describe your character he's a tech
CEO yeah yeah very secretive tech CEO
right he's he's like he's like these
sort of geniuses in Silicon Valley who
create a very powerful company except
much handsomer and hairier three hours
of prosthetics oh yes I play a guy who
invented this quantum computing company
that is in the style of Alex garland who
wrote and directed the series and he
made the movies ex machina and you know
yeah he's amazing
yeah and and he keeps asking these
questions of humanity what are you gonna
do when your technology gets too good
because you're a bunch of humans yeah
what kind of trouble are you gonna get
into yeah that's the idea that we
explore on our show so I'm a guy who has
created this computing company and have
befallen some some personal tragedy has
befallen me and that kind of drives my
decision-making and where I take the
narrative I think we have a picture
still here of your character feel like
they're always they're always putting a
halo over you or trying to figure out a
way to get you near a halo to create
this sort of like it's my brand are you
yourself I do you have you don't seem
like a tech savvy guy I will admit that
I am NOT I am NOT a tech savvy person I
am God I'm not either I love being a
Luddite I understand that our world in
many ways is driven by technology and so
I will learn to use it as much as I need
to to you know to achieve my daily
chores but I never will do anything more
like when when you know they come out
with emojis for your app I could not
give a [ __ ] about new emojis there's
actually an emoji for not giving a [ __ ]
oh there is yeah yeah as soon as I can
put down my technology and get back to
the real world my wife my family my pets
my home my woodworking my sex toys
that's why do you look so evil it's a
wonderful wonderful statement you just
made
well devs is available now exclusively
on FX on Hulu you're a scholar you're a
gentleman always wonderful to talk to
you ladies and gentlemen thank your net
bottom